antes de ser destruido por las tropas
locales este puente era la única vía de
acceso al pueblo de bogor disk en el
este de ucrania
desde que moscú anunció su intención de
centrarse en lo que llamó la liberación
del donbass los residentes de la
tradicional región minera viven con el
temor constante de un asalto know that
managers en este momento todo el mundo
está tenso todo el mundo está esperando
que ocurra algo pero en realidad no
saben lo que están esperando no gástrico
a pocos kilómetros de la línea del
frente las tropas rusas se acercan a la
zona desde el norte se han establecido
bloqueos de carreteras alrededor de
estos pueblos como parte de los
esfuerzos para frenar el avance de los
tanques rusos las tropas ucranianas
dicen que están preparadas para un
ataque como ia crucis con la federación
fascista rusa llegó a nuestra sagrada
tierra ucraniana con una espada así que
todos morirán aquí por espadas y
sargentos en este pueblo este monasterio
cuyo techo resultó dañado por las
explosiones se encuentra entre los
edificios dañados por la guerra es
beatriz está a sólo 45 kilómetros al
norte de la estratégica ciudad de sliven
las fuerzas ucranianas están desplegadas
en la zona desde 2014
y en abril de 2014 esta zona fue
capturada por un grupo de fuerzas
especiales rusas
y por lo que podemos deducir quieren
honrar este aniversario ahora capturando
slogans gaming
ante el temor de que una ofensiva rusa
sea inminente miles de civiles intentan
huir hacia el oeste cada día